hey guys Pete here it's that time of the
week again this will be my weekly
spoiler report from all the information
that's coming out of the season 7
filming locations for Game of Thrones
before we get into it I have selected
the winner for the book giveaway I post
the results in my non-spoiler
Dragonstone video that came out
yesterday be sure to check that out to
see if you are the winner I will be
starting a new giveaway this week in one
of the other non spoiler videos so check
back for that this is your final spoiler
warning if you don't want to know what
actors are doing or what might happen in
the upcoming season of Game of Thrones
before it airs stop watching now this
video contains photos from the news that
show the crew actively filming scenes
for the new episodes you've been
properly warned so now let's get into it
in the part 2 video of my mega spoilers
from last week we caught a glimpse of
the king in the north
approaching Daenerys Targaryen at
Dragonstone we get a lot more photos of
those two together this week but we
start with Jon Snow's actual rival on
the island lego date row nose posted 4
videos on their Facebook page that
showed John and Davos come ashore in
their boat they're met by Tyrion Miss
Andi and some Dothraki escorts you can
only imagine what Tyrians opener will be
here but after a little bit of posturing
we see the two shake hands
this is a really cool shot of a
westerosi King shaking hands with the
hand of the Targaryen Queen we also got
some shots of the actors talking in
between takes Watchers on the wall
reported that the Greyjoy's were absent
from this scene but Alfie Allen who
plays Theon was out but seen outside a
hotel that night in town we will get
into that more a little later in this
video this week we didn't get much in
the way of cast member sightings in
northern island early on but fans did
spot a new filming location getting
ready for shooting the pink arrow marker
showed up around the morn mountains of
County down this area has been used for
a variety of different locations from
base Toth rack to the river lands but
this year it's getting some snow early
in the week fans spotted the crew using
snowmaking equipment to ready a large
field with this little building on it
and later in the week we got some aerial
shots of what the set looks like from
above
no characters appeared on set so your
guess is as good as mine as to what
they'll be doing there it is winter in
Westeros so it doesn't have to be in the
north like usual and I didn't notice
anything that stood out as a giveaway at
you know this kind of location that's so
versatile elsewhere in Northern Ireland
another performer has returned to work
on the new season English actress
Annette Hanna who played the little bird
Frances in season six arrived in Belfast
so we have one Akai burns Birds back for
Season seven and filming will be taking
place soon no doubt Anton lesser who
plays Qyburn hasn't shown up yet but
this is exciting since we haven't seen
many of the King's Landing cast arrived
yet I mention Theon earlier when we get
our first glimpse of him on set the very
next day after we spotted him in Bilbao
in another video posted on Lego day
Toronto's his page we get a single take
filming of a scene in which Jon Davos
miss Andy and a few Dothraki received
the just arrived Theon and some Ironborn
on the shores of grog Dragonstone you
can see the degre joy signal on the
shields and must wonder what might be
going through Theon's mind as he comes
ashore as one might expect John isn't
happy to see the man who betrayed Rob
and took Winterfell by force Jon grabs
up Theon and while we can't hear what
what he's shouting at him we can tell
pretty easily that he's pissed the
couple of close ups we get from the
scene make it look pretty damn intense
fortunately for Theon the king in the
north contains himself instead of
escalating the conflict Jon apparently
just stalks off based on what we've seen
at Dragonstone so far it's safe to say
that John and Danny have already met
where this falls in the line of the
story is a bit hard to say we did also
get some director information as to
which episodes each of them are gonna be
doing this season I mention that again
later in a bit but here we just see that
Theon's there and we have no Yara in a
video I put out a couple months ago I
mentioned the battle at sea where Euron
takes the two on this is speculation of
course but it was supposed to be a rumor
that came from the set from people who
knew what was happening I have thought
that'd be a great way to open the season
up and this could be confirmation that
it happens early on if you're on
captured or killed Yara this could be
Theon returning
to the Queen to tell her what happened
finding John there would be unexpected
and I'm sure this will be a great scene
the next day multiple news sources
including the Daily Mail started
publishing a barrage of images of
Daenerys and Jon Snow together on the
set and some of the shots they are
filming around the battlements we saw
constructed a few weeks back and in
others they're just hanging out in
between takes miss Andi appears in one
or two from this patch but don't worry
there are even more of these later also
that same night the actor Ian Glen who
plays Jorah Mormont showed up in bow-bow
this was the first time he'd been caught
near the filming location so we knew
that we were gonna get some Joe very
soon sure enough on the very next day of
shooting we got a video that shows
Daenerys approaching the shore
Dragonstone where a boat is arriving in
a shot between takes we see Jorah
himself wearing a new costume and check
out Danny's getup she has the red cloak
and is sporting the complete Targaryen
look I'm not sure why this is so
exciting to me I rarely pay much
attention to what they're wearing
besides noting that it's pretty awesome
all the time but something about the red
cloak strikes a nerve with me from there
the timeline gets a little mixed up
because they're using the same location
for several different scenes in these
you know at this Beach the next photos I
saw were from a scene where Jorah is
leaving rather than coming also check
out the other people crewing this boat
with him
we have Davos on the Left John and
Gendry all getting ready to get in the
boat with Tyrion and Dany staying back
obviously this scene must be from later
in the season since we heard from good
sources that when Davos and Tyrion were
at King's Landing with Gendry that was
the fifth episode now if you're one of
those again jury doubters thinking that
it might have been Podrick in that first
scene I can assure you that this is Joe
Dempsey who plays Gendry in the close-up
picture it's plain to see by his face
and clothes that this isn't pod at all
just for good measure check out this
photo of the bunch pushing off boat is
crewed by the king in the north leading
the way Davos Gendry and Jorah plus some
other guys who are on the crew where
they're doing I have no idea but just
take a minute to think and let this sit
in these characters have been spread
across both Westeros and Essos for the
past six seasons seeing them all
together has just kind of insane
if it's if this doesn't get you hyped
for season seven knowing that they just
left Queen Daenerys Targaryen in her
hand Tyrion Lannister to set out on an
adventure together well then I don't
really know what would but there is
still more stuff that might do it so
let's just keep going cuz this is too
much the next bit of news was a surprise
for me and not in the way that all this
other stuff was this one was a casting
report which mentioned a character I
wasn't familiar with Watchers on the
wall reported that along with finding
out about all the director related news
that they found out that archmaester a
bros would be showing up in season seven
not going to lie I thought who is a bros
and when I read who he is it didn't
quite ring a bell he's just not a big
character in the books per their
reporting he is mentioned by Qyburn and
a feast for crows Qyburn mentions that
as a healer he is as skilled as a bros
but it's but he aspired to surpass him
and that is really about it he's a
healer who wears the silver mask and has
a little rod he carries around with him
Qyburn of course continued his attempt
to surpass him by doing things at the
Citadel frowned upon and that's how he
lost his chain the reason why this might
be important though is because many of
us have speculated that jim broadbent
from harry potter might be coming on to
play Marwin the mage in Sam's storyline
Marwin is one of my favorite characters
so I personally was hoping that this
would be the case on the other hand I
kind of knew that morrowind storyline
would be a complete rabbit hole for the
show to go down at this point so it
seems a lot more likely that he could be
playing this guy a bros speculate away
in the comments what you think it all
means other than him healing Jorah I'm
blanking on what his role would likely
be here on the 4th day of shooting at
zoom a more photos of the cast surface
Conleth Hill who plays Varys had been
spotted about town and we got some shots
of him on the set we got a couple of in
between takes shots were you know with
the cast lounging where the spider has
joined the others then came more photos
of Daenerys and John we get a couple
shots where they're filming a scene with
dialogue together and then we got
something that was completely crazy in
the next photos they are seen holding
these prop dragon heads / Watchers on
the wall
heads are used for different reasons
while shooting the small painted head is
used as a reference for the visual
effects team so that in the future they
know exactly how the dragon's color and
texture should look in a particular
environment meanwhile the large gray
head is usually used for contact with
the actor so that the humor performer is
actually touching something resembling
what the creature on the cgi will look
like instead of miming in the air which
I guess tends to look really kind of
faith there's no way to know for sure
what is going on here but keep in mind
that they're shooting not just playing
around now if we put two and two
together if they're using grit that
green head for proper coloring for the
visual effects then we could be
witnessing Jon Snow meeting reh gal for
the first time even more exciting is
that the dragon seems to be just fine
with their interaction Kit Harington is
holding the prop head himself which
means to me it's not making any sudden
movements and he's like literally
patting the head I think Jon Snow and
Rey gal are the dragon are becoming best
friends forever right in front of our
eyes again so much to speculate about
here I'm just gonna move on but let's
talk about all of this in the comments
for sure
after day four things got a little quiet
from zoo man this was apparently because
they were shooting inside of this caves
entrance which can't be viewed from the
cliffs nearby where the cameras have
been clicking away the cave is
mysterious but since I have no idea what
they might shoot in there I really won't
dwell on it right now
couple more photos did pop up from the
battlements though and this time we see
bears walking with Danny and her crew we
can see the grey worm has joined his
boss in these photos and some of them
seemed to be of the cache just joking
around Conleth Hill especially makes
some faces that I can't imagine seeing
bears himself mate at the end of this
batch of photos we see a couple of shots
where Jorah is arriving at Dragonstone
for the first time i guess no hints to
what the timeline is here but in the
next day's batch there are a couple
director related hints at those ones
these photos of the boat might actually
be a stuntman but it's obviously that
it's tourist character that's coming up
on shore on the final day of shooting at
the beach the Daily Mail
release some intriguing photos we see
Greyjoy's on the beach and the men are
having a go with Alfie Allen stunt
double in one of the photos it's
reported that you can see director
Jeremy Podesta who is slated to direct
the season opener and the season finale
this doesn't clear up much but it could
mean that this is just after the big sea
battle that we're hoping to see why
would Theon smen be kicking his ass well
if he made some sort of blunder at sea
you that was the reason you're on could
capture yara that would definitely get
them feeling a certain kind of way
remember your commands were more respect
from the Ironman then Theon does so that
would be my guess let me know what you
guys thinks going on here though because
really it could go either way it was a
big week but that's about the whole
bunch of everything all rolled up into
one there's a lot to speculate on here
and some surprises as well what's crazy
is that we've seen so much but there's
still a lot to come I doubt any of the
other locations will be situated in the
same way that we get this much access
but I'm guessing that we'll still have
lots to talk about in the coming weeks
please like the video if you're as hyped
as I am and let me know about your
theories in the comments make sure you
subscribe to find out about my latest
videos as soon as they're released
quick update again on the giveaway we
reach the 18,000 subscriber mark so the
winner has been picked
check out my Dragonstone video I
released yesterday to find out if you're
the winner or not I'll be announcing a
new giveaway in one of this week's and
non-spoiler videos so check back soon to
find out about that thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon